[موسيقى]
داخل المنطقه العسكريه المغلقه
امتار قليله تفصل بيننا وبين الجنود
الصينيين في قاعده هم العسكريه اول قاعده
للصين خارج الحدود
هنا في جيبوتي
[موسيقى]
الى هنا جاءت الصين لتستثمر في بلاد تبعد
عنها اكثر من خمسه الاف كيلو متر
يتنقل هذا القطار بين جيبوتي واثيوبيا
المجاوره
هذه السكه الحديديه القديمه بناها
الفرنسيون عندما استعمروا البلاد قبل 150
عام
كان نقل البضائع من شواطئ جيبوتي الى
العمق الافريقي هدفا مهما للدول الصناعيه
الكبرى
جاءت الصين بعد تلك العقود لتعيد ترميمه
وتاهيل هذا الخط وتربطه مباشره بالبحر
من هنا يتحرك القطار
اكبر الموانئ الجيبوتيه السته تنتشر على
شواطئ البلاد مع المحيط الهندي والبحر
الاحمر كل واحد منها مخصص لنوع من البضائع
اعادت الصين ايضا تاهيل الميناء وتوسعت
قدرته الاستيعابيه كل ذلك تم وفق خطه
الحزام والطريق التي اطلقتها الصين قبل
عشر سنوات اكثر من مليار دولار يوميا حجم
تجاره الصين مع الاتحاد الاوروبي التي تمر
عبر خليج عدن اكثر من 40% من اجمالي
واردات الصين النفطيه يمر عبر المحيط
الهندي
هكذا اكتسبت جيبوتي موقعا حساسا لها
وللتجار الكبار في العالم
لكننا بوابه سوق كبير في المنطقه وبالنسبه
للصينيين لديهم فهمهم الخاص بشان افريقيا
يشاهدونها على انها في منتصف العالم
ولدينا الموارد الهائله هذا هو الفهم
الصيني لافريقيا يعرف الاوروبيون
والامريكيون ذلك لكن الصينيين اسرع في
اتخاذ القرارات والتحرك يخشى الاخرون من
المخاطره بينما تخوض الصين التجربه
جعلها قبله الدول الكبرى يتنافس الجميع
لتعزيز موقعه هنا اعين نحو البحر الذي
يحمل كل هذه الاموال القادمه من التجاره
العالميه واعين كذلك نحو البر الافريقي في
العمق يتنافس الجميع ايضا لتعزيز موقعه
السياسي والاقتصادي والعسكري
[موسيقى]
على بعد ثمانيه كيلو مترات من ميناء
دورالي عام 2017 وقعت الصين وجيبوتي
اتفاقا يسمحين بانشاء قاعده عسكريه هنا
اول قاعده عسكريه صينيه خارج الحدود
[موسيقى]
علمنا من مصادر خاصه ان الصين وروسيا
كانتا تسعيان لبناء قواعد عسكريه على مضيق
باب المندب مباشره تلك البقعه الاكثر
حساسيه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
رفضت جيبوتي يقول المسؤول الذي فضل عدم
الكشف عن هويته ان بلاده ادركت المغزى
الصيني من بناء القاعده هناك السيطره
العسكريه على مضيق يعد واحدا من اهم
شرايين التجاره العالميه
على بعد ثمانيه كيلو مترات من ميناء
دولالي قررت الصين بناء القاعده
[موسيقى]
تشير لقطات للاقمار الاصطناعيه اثناء
مرحله الانشاء الى وجود عدد كبير من
المنشات تحت الارض وفق التقديرات فان
القاعده العسكريه الصينيه تضم عشره الاف
جندي
[موسيقى]
استمرت التوسع في هذه القاعده منذ تاسيسها
حتى انشاء رصيف بحري بطول 450 مترا يمكنه
استيعاب الاساطير البحريه بما فيها السفن
الحربيه الضخمه كل ذلك مقابل 20 مليون
دولار سنويا تدفعها الصين كعقد ايجار مدته
عشر سنوات
بطبيعه الحال الاقتراب من القواعد
العسكريه امر في غايه الخطوره اما
الاقتراب من القاعده الصينيه فاكثر خطوره
سلسله من الاسوار الخرسانيه الاسلاك
الشائكه والسواتر الترابيه لا يجري الدخول
او الخروج من القاعده الا في حالات محدوده
للغايه
قبل انشاء قاعده بعمل قاعده وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه ان الهدف تامين الدعم
اللوجيسي لقوه حفظ السلام الصينيه
المتمركزه في خليج عدن قباله سواحل
الصومال بالاضافه الى توفير الحمايات
للمساعده الانسانيه المقدمه من الامم
المتحده في المنطقه لكن بعد عام من انشاء
القاعده حذر عدوان بارزان في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي من العواقب السياسيه والعسكريه
اذا سيطرت الصين على الموانئ في جيبوتي
القاعده الصينيه في جيبوتي هي الوحيده
التي تملكها الصين في الخارج بينما هناك
مئات القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه في
العالم وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن الوجود
الصيني في جيبوتي علينا مقارنته بالانتشار
العسكري الامريكي الكبير في العالم
لدى جيبوتي موقع استراتيجي مهم للغايه
وكثير من السفن التجاريه الصينيه عانت
اثناء مرورها بتلك المنطقه لذلك فالسبب
وراء بناء اول قاعده خارجيه صينيه هو
حمايه السفن التجاريه من التهديدات
القادمه من الصومال
الصينيون ليسوا وحدهم هنا ترسوا سفينه
حربيه فرنسيه على الشاطئ تراج جنودا
فرنسيا يتجولون في المكان لكنك لن ترى اي
جندي صيني على كثرتهم في البلاد وفق
السكان المحليين فان الجنود الصينيين لا
يظهرون في المدينه ولا يحتكون باحد
[موسيقى]
على بعد اقل من عشره كيلومترات تتجاور
القاعدتان الامريكيه واليابانيه في زمن
متقارب انشات الدولتان الحليفتان
قاعدتيهما بررت واشنطن انشاء القاعده
انذاك بحمله محاربه الارهاب عقب غزو
العراق وافغانستان عللت اليابان بناء
قاعدتها الاولى خارج الحدود بمحاربه
القرصنه في واحد من اهم خطوط التجاره
العالميه هذا الى جانب قاعده فرنسيه من
بقايا الاستعمار الذي دامت تسعين عاما
[موسيقى]
عام 2018 اشتكت واشنطن رسميه لدى بيجين من
تعرض طيارين امريكيين لاشعه ليزر مصدرها
القاعده الصينيه اشتكت بجيل واشنطن من
الاشتباه بمحاولات تجسس الامريكيه
اليابانيه على القاعده الصينيه هكذا ينظر
الجميع بعين الريبه الى بعضهم لا يريد اي
من هؤلاء ان يفصح مجالا للاطراف الاخرى
لكن جيبوتي لها راي كما تقول فتحنا
ابوابنا للدول التي تستطيع ان ان تساهم
وتساعد عسكريه في يعني مكافحه الارهاب
والقرصنه وتهريب البشر وغيرها من الاعمال
الاجراميه التي تحصل في في مضيق
باب المندب وخليج عدن والبحر الاحمر ثانيا
نحن ايضا عندنا بحريه في الاونه الاخيره
يعني اشترينا كثير من القطعه البح ريه
ونساهم ليس فقط يعني في استضافه هذه
القوات البحريه الاجنبيه في جيبوتي ولكن
نساهم ايضا من خلال هذه
[موسيقى]
الاليات التي يعني
نملكها
للمساهمه في امن ملاحه وسلامه ملاحه السفن
في هذه المنطقه
هذه مياه باب المندب احد اهم الممرات
المائيه في العالم من هنا يمر عشره في
المئه من التجاره العالميه والى هنا ياتي
الجميع لحمايه الحركه التجاريه كما يقولون
لا يتجاور الجيشان الصيني والامريكي في اي
مكان في العالم لكنهما يفعلان ذلك هنا
جيبوتي هذه البقعه الجغرافيه الصغيره التي
يتنافس الجميع على موطئ قدم فيها بحثا عن
مكاسب اقتصاديه لكن الاهم تثبيت وجود يفتح
الابواب امام نفوذ سياسي وعسكري في القاره
الافريقيه كلها على المدى البعيد صهيب
العصا الجزيره جيبوتي